merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu deviens petit dans ton cirque de vieillesse
un destin que tu ne partageras pas
Je suis dans ton Ombre depuis des heures mais
comme rien de pathétique
j'ai demandé un égal
et c'est ce que tu trouves
monsieur
peut-être
un nouveau  terrain de chasse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allumez les feux,
la grande chasse commence
[Musique]
très bien,
c'est cité dans le Queens, ce qui fait que maintenant
couvrez la porte,
la Bête pourrait être n'importe où
vous n'avez aucune idée de
ce que vous voulez chasser, je vais  donnez-lui un
qu'il n'oubliera jamais,
il va gagner
des positions de triangulation
Cible située au marché aux poissons de Harlem toutes les
équipes convergent les lézards à travers la rivière
Je n'arriverai pas à temps
[Musique] des
kilomètres les chasseurs traquent Connors jusqu'au
marché aux poissons de Harlem
dessert, j'y suis, on dirait que Craven
éteint le sien, nous n'avons pas beaucoup de temps pour
bouger,
je suppose que nous en discuterons plus tard.
Genki le lézard est en liberté au
marché aux poissons, ça doit être la soirée sushi, tu as toujours
ce chasseur qui te jette en détour et
vraiment dur.  je le cache pour ma mère mais
ouais je vais démarrer et on se voit là-bas,
ils sont arrivés vite
[Musique]
nous ne pouvons pas les laisser trouver Connors
fini pour ça
[Musique] [
Musique]
étalez-les,
trouvez-les, c'est que ça ne s'engage pas  seul
regarde ces poissons qu'il nourrit
merci les
étrangers le
garage pourrait le conduire
Connor a déchiré cet endroit
[Musique]
contrôle
oh
mon Dieu
où suis-je maintenant
comment me trouves-tu suis les
drones poissons ramassant les lézards Sentier
qu'il mange encore  nous pouvons le prendre au dépourvu
Yankee, mets-toi derrière moi,
c'est juste sa peau,
cela ne veut pas dire qu'il a de plus en plus faim
aussi,
allez
whoa amen,
de nouveaux fils de discussion, le bâtiment grouille de
chasseurs, tout signe de Connors euh ouais, les
Yankees le traquent hé M. Parker, M.
Spider-  Mec, ce que je veux dire,
mais le rendez-vous n'est pas complet,
ok, je pense que j'en ai eu beaucoup, as-tu attendu, tu te
détends,
ce n'était pas moi, moi non plus, je n'ai même pas d'
estomac, alors allons-y, allons-y,
rends-le vivant, je
ne peux pas perdre.  Connors Harry est en train de mourir et
il est le seul qui peut aider, nous ne
prendrons pas le drone. J'ai bien les jet skis
si j'emprunte ça,
c'est vraiment très excitant, garde-le
serré, mec, fais attention à ces drones,
ne t'inquiète pas, ils pensent que je  Je suis un sympathique
East River n'est pas une rivière, mais en fait,
l'appartement pour le titre d'eau salée
sur lequel Spiderman se bat en ce moment,
aidez la porte à voter, c'est vrai. J'ai l'
oiseau meurtrier en métal, je vous avais
prévenu de vous en prendre à Connor,
maintenant c'est sur vous
des nuages ​​qui  tout ce que vous avez
presque fait ici, les civils sont tous en sécurité,
comment allez-vous,
l'hélicoptère de combat ne s'arrêtera pas, je suis juste derrière vous,
nous allons l'abattre ensemble, pas le temps,
je vous ai le temps de faire du boum, les garçons non non non
Spider-Man.  il y a des défenses
Spider-Man accroche-toi là-
bas
[Musique]
reviens on y va c'est
juste derrière toi je sais je sais whoa
Steve Master vole plus vite
je ne veux pas être de la nourriture pour lézard
merci
tiens bon
tout le monde mettez-vous à l'abri
qu'est-ce que vous faites les gars  J'essaie d'
éliminer ce vaisseau de combat, je ne peux pas m'approcher suffisamment,
mais je ne peux pas, je suis l'un d'entre eux, souviens-toi, mon frère, c'est tout,
hey alley-oop sur trois salut
un deux trois Ally,
il s'est éloigné de nous,
c'est bien Pete,
j'ai sauvé le tracker.
allons-y mec avant qu'il n'aille trop loin non, c'est à
moi,
tu es sûr qu'il
a de grandes dents, moi aussi
[Musique] je le
fais, euh, il n'est pas normalement comme ça,
non,
il n'est jamais comme ça
[Applaudissements]